I love Hamza he's he's so bad he's good
yeah as a comedian he's brilliant
because he comes out and he says he says
things you know let's put male rapists
in women's prisons and you go you can't
ride this stuff this is absolutely
brilliant we get Isla Bryson who
basically
identifies as a woman because he found
he found a wig in a Skip and some
Primark leggings and now said right I'm
a two-time rapist but I don't really
fancy going to a male jail let's put me
in a women's shell and hamsa says yes
and of course Hamza should say yes
because no one knows what a woman is
Nana I don't know what you are I'm a
woman really yes what is a woman a woman
doesn't have a penis right that is
incredibly transphobic and I demand
everyone on Twitter who is watching it
cancel her immediately get rid of her no
one gets canceled on my show really no
one gets canceled but afternoon get out
seriously but I don't know somewhere
politicians are struggling with this
very simple notion of what a woman is
and tripping over themselves to get it
wrong well no one is struggling what the
definition of a woman is not no one is
at all because everybody knows right
from when they were born what a boy is
and what a girl is it's it's basic
biology no one is struggling with it
Nana more people are struggling with is
they are terrified of alienating a
particularly vocal minority of our shall
we say voter base or more accurately
those people on social media and they're
terrified that they're gonna get
canceled they're going to get smeared as
transphobic and their careers are going
to be put at an end but at some point
people need to stand up and go look this
is nonsense we can't keep carrying on
like this and it's fine we've got be
honest about biology my daughter she
said she's terrified of all this she
said that somebody said that there's now
a hundred and something genders there's
Panda gender yeah of course I mean come
on because if you're going to do that
then every individual could make their
own gender up if you don't fit into the
gender one that's why at Birth they say
gender yes male female so that's in my
view there are two people and where you
fit on that is somewhere in between but
it's still a combination of the two well
the reality is those men and those women
now how you feel and how you think of
yourself that's something else you want
to Define that as gender I mean I I
wouldn't that wouldn't be the definition
I'd have put on it no but they have
disassociated sex with gender of course
but the reality is there's just male and
then there's female now if you think you
you want to be non-binary then that is
your right but the reality is non-binary
doesn't exist you're male one
it sounds controversial to say that it's
not controversial non-binary doesn't
exist and people go well I don't want to
be put into a category because I'm
Winery well you've just created a
category put yourself in one that
doesn't exist yes
[Music]